Loretta napoleoni spent years
researching her book modern jihad
tracing the dollars behind the terror
networks it's an examination of how
terrorist networks like al-qaeda and
Italy's Red Brigades protect their money
this lasts an hour thank you very much
thank you for coming even if the weather
is not so fantastic I try to arrange it
but unfortunately I couldn't um I'm
going to UM tell you the story of this
book which i think is very interesting
and then after we can have question and
answer and you can ask me about the
broken about this economy of terror I
started researching terrorism in the
early 1990s at that time I was working
for a stockbroker in London and I just
had a baby and I was approached by a
friend who at that time was looking
after the rights of Italian former
members of terrorist organizations in
jail he came to me with a very unusual
request he actually asked me if I was
interested in interviewing the Red
Brigades this was quite surprising to me
first of all because I had lived abroad
for 15 years so i was living in london
at that time so i had no contact
whatsoever with the political
environment of italy but also i did not
really understand why after 30 years of
silence the Red Brigades wanted to talk
to me now as part of their strategy to
find the italian state their abrogates
never actually at any communication
whatsoever with the italian state which
means they never talk to journalists
they SAT through their trials in
I'll answer refusing even to talk to the
defense lawyers in 1992 the founding
group of the Red Brigades decided to
issue a document whereby they declared
that the armed struggle was over this
because the political condition in Italy
had changed so much since the 1960s that
they didn't see any reason why they
should continue fighting the italian
state at that point they decided that
they would tell their story to somebody
and that person was me so when I enquiry
about why do we do why they wanted to
talk to me I was given us an answer the
following one of my childhood friend she
was a leader of the red brigades I had
discovered the day she was arrested by
opening the newspaper she was
instrumental in the kidnapping the trial
and the execution of all tomorrow so she
was given 35 years and a couple of life
sentences I had been in touch with her
after she was arrested we had exchanged
letters but she had never ever mentioned
anything about our decision to become a
terrorist she'll never discuss politics
in these letters either I was also in
the 1970s very active political in the
feminist movement now several members
female members of the Red Brigades it
actually been part also the feminist
movement and then again we didn't nobody
knew until they were arrested so they
the female members of the Red Brigades
they thought that they could talk to me
that was always one of the best person
because they knew me because I was an
economist I was not to journalist at
that time I was not linked to any
political party and i was living abroad
and they thought that I was going to be
as objective as possible in telling
their story
so I I thought a lot about that because
I had to quit my job I had to spend a
lot of time in Italy so I had to leave
my family behind it and I decided to do
it for personal reasons I really wanted
to know why my childhood friend had
become a terrorist I mean what was what
made her take up arms against the other
human beings but above all I wanted to
find out why none of these people had
ever tried to recruit me yeah I as I
knew so many of them so I decided to to
interview them I went back to university
I went back to the London School of
Economics and I enroll in a PhD program
and very very soon I discovered the
answer to my questions now the reason
why my childhood friend had become a
terrorist is because she was convinced
that Italy was a blocked democracy now
Italy was the country which was ruled by
the Christian Democratic Party from 1946
until in 1980 so the reason why Italy
was a block democracy in in their mind
and most of your the left-wingers mind
was that the United States was
conditioning the political decision of
Italy there was a particular incident
1978 when they Italian Communist Party
actually won the political elections so
they could form a communist government
or at least a left-wing government the
day after the election the members of
the Communist Party did not show up in
Parliament according to data and
parliamentary law the majority present
in the Chamber's can form a government
so they gave the possibility to the
Christian Democrats to form another
Christian Democrats government
there was a scandal in Italy people were
very very upset and the leader of the
Communist Party when public saying that
the reason why he did it it was because
he was afraid that easily will be the
next chillin so that was the kind of
atmosphere of Italy in the 1970s and a
lot of people like my friend so that the
only way to unblock this democracy was
through political violence so this is
why she became a terrorism the reason
why they didn't recruit me is because I
did not fit the psychological profile
they did very careful profiling them all
terrorist organization actually target
their recruitment by doing serious
profiling your political ideas are not
so important at all because they will
mold you once you are in the
organization the important thing is that
you will fit an earlier article
organization where there is the
management at the very top and Tina
orders come from the top there is no way
you can question order and whatever
you're told you have to do it to a
certain extent is very similar to an
army and I was judged too opinionated
too single-minded and they told I was
going to be a real troublemaker so this
is why first-ever recruits me I know
it's quite um anyway so when um i
discovered this i I also began
discovering something else which was
quite intriguing to me i discovered that
the daily life of a member of the Red
Brigades was ruled by economics and not
by politics they never discuss politics
they never discussed the ideology I mean
the olders the line the political line
came from the top and once you were in
there was nothing to say anymore but
every day they had to find new ways to
raise money because they needed money
cause
the money to carry out their next attack
they needed money to buy arms they need
money to buy safehouses renting
different places it was a constant
search for money now just to give you an
idea of the tool Nova of the replicates
in the 1970s they organization at 500
members full-time and then over 1500
part-timers the full timers were
completely underground so the
organization ID to pay for everything
the amount of money in the 1970s
required to run the Red Brigades I was
between eight to ten million dollars
which is equivalent to 80 to 100 million
dollars today so we're talking about a
lot of money we're also talking about a
lot of management of the money how you
going to raise the money oh you're going
to distribute the money how are you
going to invest the money in order to
have even more money so this is what i
discovered interviewing the Red Brigades
and interestingly enough they were quite
for coming in telling me different ways
they actually I think they were very
proud sometimes there was somebody who
told me a story about sailing from Italy
regularly up to Lebanon to pick up arms
for all the various armed organization
of Europe but this is what their
abrogates actually did for quite a while
they will pick the arms from the PLO in
Lebanon than they would sail back to
Sardinia and then the other armed
organization of Europe the IRA they add
the baader-meinhof would travel to
salina pick up the arms and the replicas
will get a cat out of this service and
and the person who told me it's actually
the guy who owned the boat it was a
psychiatrist what Johnny so we joined
the Red Brigades and it was a keen say
Loria the beautiful boat and he had done
this journey
of times and it was really proud when he
told me that so I got so much
information from them that I decided
that I really ought to focus on this and
concentrate my research on the economics
of terror is not on the ideology
unfortunately I couldn't change my PhD
halfway through because this is not
allowed so I decided to find some
alternative funds to conduct my research
I approached several universities I
approached foundations and the answer
was always no this is in the mid-1990s
people just look at me as if you know I
was talking a foreign language they just
couldn't grasp the concept of the
economics of terrorism so I went to my
literary agent and I asked her if she
could get me a contract with the
publisher to write a book about that and
this is 1996 my literary agent said
there's no way I'm going to get you any
money terrorism is a dead subject yes
she's still my agent and she still
apologized for that sentence but the
truth is that in 1996 in Europe
terrorist was a dancer objector I with
the Red Brigades had been defeated by
the miners for had been defeated ada was
virtually non active at that time in
spain and the IRA was in the process of
negotiating a peace treaty with the
united kingdom so there was not really
terrorism in Europe so the European said
I gone through three decades of
terrorism and they didn't want to talk
about that anymore they just wanted to
get on with life so I carried on my
research by myself I did accumulate a
very large archive and I worked with a
capital professors in the United Kingdom
who were actually writing books and
research in terrorism then in two
thousand I approach
a literary agency in New York was quite
a famous literary agency and I and the
reason why I came to the state is
because I was observing the pattern of
Islamic terror in the Middle East and in
Africa and to me was clear they were
targeting Americans and American
interests there so I thought perhaps in
the US I'll find a different answer to
my question so I approached them and
they were very interested with the idea
but they said there is no way we can get
you a contract nobody in this country's
interested in terrorism is just not a
subject so I I carried on doing my
research by myself and then the 12 of
sep tember 2001 my phone never stopped
ringing because all of those people that
contact over a decade they wanted my
book of course I didn't have a book
because nobody yet finance Spartanburg
so I went back to the literary agents in
New York and they said okay put out a
proposal for a book on the economics of
terrorism and you will sell the book no
problem so I've wrote this proposal very
quickly in three weeks because I add all
the information and the proposal went
out to 24 publishers now we're talking
about commercial publishers of course
and then 18 commissioning editor
immediately wanted to buy the book so
the agency decided to to go to auction
to do a literary auction and one by one
the commissioning editor dropped out of
the option and the reason why they did
that is because they were blocked or the
book was veto by the board of directors
of the various publishing company zhem
so when we finally found out what was
the real reason for blocking the book we
were told what something that maybe I
should have thought about this before is
the fact that i presented islamic terror
as the third stage of an evolutionary
trend of terrorism which started after
World War Two and I presented it as an
international network of banks charities
organist commercial organization
businessman traders in system which is
widespread which is top to our system
and his feeding an economy which is
keeping terrorism all over the world
going what at that time the publishers
wanted and also the press was a sort of
description of the enemy as an insane
irrational religious group of fanatic
people living deeply into the caves of
Afghanistan am not willing even knew to
consider the pleasures of the Western
world and this was the problem the
problem was that this country was not
ready for a book that was describing the
enemy as somebody almost like us and it
just didn't take it so we went to
England where we had exactly the same
response only this time it was more
serious because we were on our way to
sign a contract with one of the top
publisher and we got a phone call saying
that the president of the publishing
house that actually blocked the book
because it didn't want a book like that
to be published so at that point I
decided that the I had enough of
mainstream publishing in the US or and
in the UK so I went to Italy and my
agent in Italy sold the book in 12 hours
at an auction I got the largest
advancement that's an entirely never got
for a Boca I also managed to convince
the publisher in Italy that I really
wanted to write a book in english
because i thought you know the English
market was far the most important market
so they agree that I would write it
booking
english and they would translate the
book from english into italian which is
my mother tongue so now the book is out
here but it's not out in Italy because
they are translating a book which is the
mail um then we sold it the agents my
Italian agent sold it to the French the
Spanish the the Germans so it was sold
to many other European companies
countries in translation but I couldn't
sell at the right so my book in english
because i had a contract with the
literary agency and the literary agency
blocked me from going to small
publishers so what they wanted me to do
they wanted me to sit on the book for
like in a couple of years until the
American market would be ready for it
and then they would make the big sale
but I didn't want to because this is not
this is for me it's really not a
business that venture for me it's almost
a mission of my life I mean I wanted
this book to be ready 10 years ago so I
was not prepared to wait for other two
years which point I had to fire the
agents in wait for the contract to
expire so finally in the in january i
was able to approach its general 2002 i
was able to approach English independent
publisher there only 3 left in England
and I got offered for the three of them
then in the end i went with pluto press
because it was it was the one that i
thought was the best that also for
promoting the book and getting the book
out to two people and so this is a this
is this I think this is an amazing story
of you know how hard it is sometimes to
write a book which then when it comes
out is very topical because as a result
of my six weeks book tour in the States
this is actually my last leg of the tour
I must say that there is too much
interest in this topic and he comes from
every single the section of society
I even went to give a little talk to an
ice cold in in Montana and the children
were amazing because they were asking me
all those questions they really wanted
to know what is going on so at least we
managed to get it out at least we
managed to get people interested so to
me this is already a great achievement
so now we can do their question
uncertain do you have to wait for the
microphone this is the rule that way if
you have a few minutes I'll ask a
question but also if you could maybe
expand a little on the actual thesis of
your book beyond what you did in the
beginning I think this is the story of
the book itself is interesting but an
observation is that aside from the end
purpose which it seems like a great
amount of similarity between the
terrorists raising a bunny and let's say
the Mafia you know as the Mafia was
interested in raising money simply for
the purpose of acquiring money for the
purpose of acquiring more money and they
had no agenda other than to control
power as such but not overthrow a
government while in the case of the
terrorists they want the money for as
you said for other purposes like know if
you'e comment on that observation
whether I'm right or wrong or whether or
what yeah there is an entire chapter on
that in the book basically what I
discovered in my research is that the
contrary to what many people have said
and I've written in armed organization
it's absolutely not run like a
multinational crime I mean there are
lots of similarities especially in the
way they raise money through illegal and
criminal operation but the truth is that
the final aim of Cosa Nostra or the
Mafia is purely accumulation of wealth
the final aim of a terrorist
organization is not so much accumulation
of wealth but distribution of wealth so
you have to manage to send the money
first we automate to generate the money
and then once you have generated the
money you have to manage to distribute
this money across the spectrum of your
various sells slippers or even your
organization which are affiliated to you
so in that I came to the conclusion that
the terrorist organization operates more
likely a state than a criminal
organization because what is the final
aim of a state it is actually the
distribution of wealth what Lisa should
be so so this is why I when I looked at
the way the terrorist organization
raised money and spend money I instead
of using the balance sheet of the
corporation I use the balance of
payments so i divided the revenues and
the expenditure into in sections for the
balance of payments and that's exactly
what this is three chapters of the book
are all about specifically that
okay we said from here I wanted to ask
you about the landscape for for
terrorist financing in Eastern Europe in
the aftermath of the collapse of
communism in the region and I had some
experience in Bosnia in the 90s and two
years ago I was supposed to go to
Sarajevo and our trip was canceled
because there was intelligence
information that a lieutenant of Osama
bin Laden was living there he had taken
a Bosnian wife and all these so-called
freedom fighters who had taken up the
cause of the Muslims in the Bosnian
conflict had set up quote unquote
legitimate businesses which were now
under suspicion for being conduits for
terrorist financing and also that in
this vacuum created in the region that
Saudi Arabia for one had committed 50
million dollars for the construction of
mosques for the promotion of Wahhabism I
don't know if I'm pronouncing it
correctly what did you find I do what
have you found out about that is that is
that is that an overstated problem in
Bosnia or is it one that is also
repeated in the rest of the southeast
Balkans I there's a lot of illegal
trading in drugs and and women
throughout Kosovo and Macedonia also
where is this money going well what I am
in my book is what I described the
Islamic colonization of certain regions
which were region under they added the
sub part of the Soviet Union former
Soviet una or the were Regent like
Bosnia for example that were ruled by a
communist regime now with the fall of
the Berlin Wall and the fall of the
Soviet Union this region were freed for
various organization primarily Islamic
banks to penetrate this region and
establish economic strong roles now one
thing that I have discovered
searches that islamic banks until 1989
1990 had been really at the fringe of
the international banking system they
were only operationally inside the
various muslim countries where they
operated and they did a lot of good work
domestically but also they establish
links with the various black market in
the Middle East switch which at the time
and even today are extremely very well
developed then with the folded Soviet
Union and the following d regularization
of the market they actually had the
opportunity to expand this for the first
time ever so and they moved into those
countries like Central Asian Republic
the Caucasus and of course Bosnia
Albania where there was a sort of
transition order transition from one
regime to another or Ashley void of
political power and when this took place
is strategic alliance was formed and
mostly it comes from Saudi Arabia so
under the umbrella of religion under
umbrella of Islam of the return to the
purity of Islam and alliance was forged
between an emerging middle class which
is primarily bankers and merchants and
traders and the radical clerics the
wahhabis now both wanted to expand but
wanted to proselytize the religious
belief at the same time you also to
expand economically and this was the
golden opportunity the problem was that
in in many of these countries of course
they there was a an inviting during the
transition so there was either a foreign
power or there was a regime in place
which was extremely unpopular among the
Muslim population so they use Islamic
terror Islamic armed organization as a
sort of the Vanguard which we move into
these countries and create the ideal
conditions for you know the various
and traders to move in and help the
economy which was generally on the verge
of collapsing now Albania is a very good
example because with the pyramid scheme
in Albanian the 1990s two thirds of the
wealth of the population was wiped away
I mean people were really starving in
Albania so and this is when al-qaeda was
very active in ovarian they moved in
they establish their own various groups
the new movie Adina of course as they
called them and then the Saudi banks and
Iranian banks moved into the country
offering very cheap actually virtually
free credit and soon after the traders
moved in and they took over the entire
economy of the country so that's the
legal side of course of the business but
together with that there is also the
legal side these countries are all on
the drug route there are other you know
drug producers like Afghanistan or
transshipment points like Chechnya and
of course the Balkans so together these
two I would say is like a two-tier
market the legal and illegal they have
established their own economy and
they've linked up their own economy with
the other armed organization economies
and this is part of this international
economic system
I don't understand how big an economy
exists in terrorism it seems to me the
nature of a terrorist group in the
Middle East is almost self-sustaining
it's small its self-sustaining they
don't need a lot of money to do what
they do the arms are around the the
explosives are there how do they use
them money what do they need this money
for it's easy to go into business
without having bankers in Saudi Arabia
do support you in what you're doing how
big is it it's very big as some there
the terror economy alone which is the
economy that is generated primarily by
armed organization sustained by our
organization is 500 billion dollars per
year that's the turnover which 400
billion seize illegal narcotics the drug
and then 100 billion sees other
smuggling activities which is can be
anything races from smuggling of people
to you know arms then then there is the
illegal illegal it's cool actually
capital flight but in reality it is
mostly it's money they move from one
country to another you know illegally
undetected and are recorded and this
ranges from tax evasion to the legal
businesses of terror organization which
are clean money used for you know
criminal activities or terrorist
activities and this is another five
hundred billions and then the third
component is the what is the define as
the gross criminal product and it's 500
billions again and this is all the
criminal of money money the like Cosa
Nostra is part of it arms smuggling
through the various mafia organization
so the total is 1.5 trillion dollars now
this is my calculation but it's happened
to coincide with the calculation of the
IMF so mmm it's 1.5 trillion
it's equivalent to one enough the GDP of
the United Kingdom which means that it
is the second largest economy in the
world after the United States this
microphone just a just a follow-through
questions so what you're saying I think
is that a lot of people making a lot of
illegal money but the actual act of
terrorism to go and attack an embassy
doesn't require much money at all no no
yes sure I mean the maybe I should
explain that what has happened in the
1990s is that the terror economy has
merged with the illegal and criminal
economy so therefore one system now
these are people that buy weapons from
the same companies these are people that
money launder dirty money through the
same institutions they move money
through the same banks so this is why I
consider it as a system that doesn't
mean that the criminal money and the
terror money are used in the same way
terror money are exclusively used to
carry out terrorist terrorist attacks to
sustain the system so they go to pay for
people who are on full time payroll of
the various armed organization the
underground people it is true that
carrying out a terrorist attack is
relatively cheap 911 calls only five
hundred thousand dollars that's the
actual implementation of the attack but
they worked on that for a decade so they
are there were people involved in the
planning for a decade so the actual cost
is much higher but that's the only cost
we calculate because we can really we
can't calculate exactly how much it
costs
the microphone we lost them okay the one
of the things that's puzzled me since
911 and all this publicity about money
moving around the world and that in
secrecy is we look at the Swiss banking
system where we look at the Cayman
Islands places like this where even
Americans take advantage of the secrecy
that's there do you feel that if this
were to be opened up whether it be
forcefully or however that this would
help slow down this flow of money
through the terrorist organizations
around the world absolutely I think one
of the problem that we have it is the
financial and economic theory
colorization I mean the globalization of
our economy was a great thing for
Western capitalism but it was also a
great thing for international terrorism
because they could use that the same
facilities then we're using up so
offshore banking is is key is a key link
in the way this money get distribute
within the international organization
network how are we going to regulate
that that's going to be a very big
problem because of course it's going to
hurt our system because we're so used
now to ever an economy and international
economy which is free I mean I can go
anywhere in the world with my cash point
card from the United Kingdom and I can
get cash but so can an affiliate ha bin
Laden and we don't think about this but
the truth is that it is our system also
that facilitates the way they can raise
money and they can distribute the money
and this is also part of the
relationship between the two system i
mean we're very much intertwined with
with them how can you not be linked to
an economy that is 1.5 trillion dollars
that the majority of this money flows
into the united states and europe
because the money laundering center of
the world is in the United
I mean the the Treasury Department
recently admitted the 99 percent of the
money which are brought into this
country illegally for money laundering
gets through the system ninety-nine
percent and the Patriot Act is actually
not doing anything to block this money
where would the patriotic maybe is
moving in the right direction but the
truth is that if somebody from Africa
decides to open an account in a bank in
Florida and transfer from Africa 10
million dollars the banking florida will
take the 10 million dollars without
asking where are the 10 million dollars
coming from if you want to open an
account now in this can today we'll ask
you lots of information but the money
are not in this country the money are
coming from outside sorry dude that's
right so so how do we stop this flow of
money that's flying around the world
well that's a very big problem i was at
the conference at the Brookings
Institution two not three weeks ago
action on money laundering that was one
of the key issue of the conference we
cannot stop this money overnight because
if you take 1.5 trillion dollars out of
the Western economy will go deeply
deeply into recession so that's the
first step is just to do it over a long
period of time maybe a decade is a bit
like being a drug addict and having to
win your body out of the drugs the other
way the other strategy it is to reduce
the money laundering flow because the
majority of the money come through that
system the money laundering so better
legislation especially more control over
banks they accept money from outside
one proposal was that to ask banks to
have the documentation legal
documentation for every single transfer
that is over ten thousand dollars so
that's another way but I think the most
important strategy it is to understand
why this is taking place why are these
people coming after Western interests
why have they built the system and why
they are terrorists and that's something
that will require I think an in-depth
analysis of the politics of the Middle
East and the Muslim world but also it
will require a drastic change in our
foreign policy I mean we cannot continue
to sustain governments which are clearly
not only on Democratics but they're
breaking every single human rights who
are oppressing the people that's that's
unfeasible to continue to to follow that
route eventually of course you know we
will run into troubles as we did so a
combination of economic tools is
definitely very important with a
combination of your change in foreign
policy okay
did you do that one next and then we do
okay from an economic standpoint do you
think that we are looking at individuals
who want to make a quick dollar or
looking at a system that's looking for
world domination I there's no
individuals they want to make a quick
dollar they will go into criminal
activity if they wanted to do that and
there is plenty of opportunity in the
western end Muslim word for that I don't
think they want to war domination either
I actually happen to believe that this
is an insurgent movement the conclusion
from my research is that we're
witnessing a clash between two economic
system one is dominant which is the west
and the other one is insurgent which is
the East analyzing why this is taking
place I discover that as I said before
religion is only an umbrella is the
ideological umbrella under which an
alliance has been forged and the
Alliance is with the middle class the
emerging middle class which was formed
in in all produced Arab oil producing
countries in the mid 1970s with the
first oil shock when there was a massive
transfer of wealth from the west to all
producing countries the radical clerics
we want a regime change because they
perceive the existing oligarchy regimes
as to pro Western and also they perceive
them as the regime were departed from
the original idea impurity of Islam and
the third component which is the most
important component is the people is
actually the masses of people the Muslim
in the various Muslim countries who have
been oppressed by the oligarchic
corrupted regimes for a couple of
decades already I mean these people are
now experiencing massive demo
growth there are no jobs that is there
are no money and the appeal of this
insurgency is fantastic to them because
there is a way to change the life from
bad situation to in a much better
situation but also most important is a
way to make some money because these
people are paid by the organization of
the join as a corollary to that though
if we look at the country so we believe
our supporting terrorism those are the
same countries where there should be
insurrection and there isn't and
basically you know the concept is is
they will pay as much as needed to have
the devil do his deed in a different
country as opposed to theirs and the
question arises do they have an agenda
of which which is part of all of this
and I guess the question again about
world domination of you know whether
it's religious economic or what-have-you
of a certain group of people that right
now have a great deal of wealth um I
suppose you're referring to Saudi Arabia
writer okay there is a massive activity
terrorist activity in Saudi Arabia we
simply don't know because you know
nobody can go to Saudi Arabia there are
no news coming out of Saudi Arabia but
if you talk to the Saudi dissidents who
actually have their headquarters in
London you discover that there is
activity inside Saudi Arabia in fact in
the United Kingdom there are few proofs
or that because a group of British
people have been kept for three years in
jail in isolation confinement have been
beaten they've been tortures they've
been put on trial they've been condemned
and the British ambassador was not
allowed to see them this is because they
were accused were put a couple of bombs
in Riyadh which in fact were bombs put
by the Islamic so they blame the British
because they needed a cover-up
eventually these people have been
released
at the end of August after the Bush
administration has been particularly
negative about the way the Saudis were
handling their war on terror and been
reports on his people actually have been
spoken with the press and they've
described as Saudi Arabia as the place
where there are attacks continuously
shopping malls in front of schools in
front of this drinking club so this is
where this bomb was actually but this
the fact is we don't know this is not
reported so that's something that I
think we have to bear in mind the other
they don't think that I want to tell you
is that this reports that we hear about
the fact that the Saudi are actually
paying protection money to Osama bin
Laden I have not come across any of this
so that's my research but then does your
book make any distinction at all between
the economics of terrorism and economic
terrorism the use of you know things
that my other terrorist activities that
are economic in nature for example after
September 11th there is concern or
thoughts that the Muslim fundamentalist
were selling short on the market at the
form of terrorism you know to drive our
prices down but your book me any
distinction between the economics how
would they finance themselves as opposed
to using economics as a meat as a
terrorist activity itself yeah and then
yes in the balance of payments that I
was describing before in the list in the
list in many revenues there is in fact
an asset number 11 speculation and there
is a description of how they did it and
also calculation roughly of how much
money they made now this is comes from
an official report from the Bundesbank
of the German Bundesbank where she's day
only bad
girl who has gone public on the
September 11 speculation in this country
the Fed the Federal Reserve has not gone
public but they know exactly how much
money were made because it's very easy
to calculate especially in that week
because they apparently that the
activity in certain markets and
particularly the insurance market and
the future markets for shares of
airlines funny enough they are excited
the airlines that we use in their tax
the activity went up in certain dates
two hundred percent so they know that
not only do the knock down the tower
spending five hundred thousand dollars
they also made maybe you know ten times
over me even more 100 times over that
amount by speculating on the stock
exchange
I'd like to know your thoughts on the
Homeland Security Department that's been
recently developed here and also
organizations like it if there is one
that exists somewhere else and how
successful they can be in policing it it
seems like it's a very reactive and like
you were saying some of these regimes
have been at where people have been in
place for 10 years is there any way that
we can actually police it from a from a
proactive perspective versus a reactive
one no there is no way you can please
this country or any country and my
experiences from Italy we had 30 years
of terrorist activity and then it'll is
much much smaller than the US and it was
a completely different period in history
so there were borders there were in a
much stricter controls the word foreign
exchange regulations today the degree of
freedom of armed organization like the
replicates was much much lower than the
degree of freedom of Islamic terror and
we did not succeed at all the truth is
you cannot police the entire nation it's
impossible I mean you cannot stop
flights in this morning I came from New
York on the shuttle we were told that we
could not stand up during the flight so
we were told when the doors closed
nobody can stand up this is a new
security regulation so everybody SAT
from Washington DC to New York without
moving the what do you do I mean I was
with my research assistant and she said
well what are they going to do if we
were going to London well maybe we had
to sit until we were in mid-atlantic
there is no way you can police and also
there is no way you can you you can even
attempt to police without affecting the
population of this country without
reducing the the freedom of the people
in this country so in the end you're
going to hurt your own people which is
not what you really want to do and this
is why I again think that we have to
lose
not inside our country now inside the
West but we have to look at this we have
to find a solution in those countries
because this is where the problem is we
have to go to the root of the problem
and this is something unfortunately I
don't think any of the Western
governments have done so far oh no sorry
this last it's just getting interesting
is the questioning look I'm curious as
to whether or not you are consulted by
any of the government's or influential
organizations around the world on this
issue no I work only with the the crime
and Prevention Unit of sorry the crime
and terrorist Prevention Unit of the
United Nation in Vienna that's the only
organizational work but i do not work
officially with them I work unofficially
with them because they had that unit is
a scholar in on terrorism and I have no
name for a decade so I've been in touch
with him through all of these years that
I have been approached only by the this
unit of the United Nation if the State
Department comes to me and said do you
want to work full time for us I would
say no because I don't want to work for
the state department I don't want to
work full time for any of these
organizations if they want my opinion if
they want me to be a consultant and help
them I'll be very very happy I even do
it for free but I don't want to be part
of any establishment the moment to which
you get into any established including
academia you get boxed in and your
degree of freedom in researches gets
very reduced some of my sources will not
talk to me either if I do that so I have
to stay free
these are living next I'd like to know
if this is a war of the an economic war
and not a religious war what what is the
goal of the terrorists are they trying
to share the wealth is that what you're
saying is it a socialism a farmer
socialism well the Islamic terrorist
organization is really the tip of the
iceberg what makes this organization
operate and function is actually a real
economic forces now this real economic
forces are what I described as the
embryo of the Islamic bourgeoisie these
are people who have established a
certain kind of wealth were since the
mid 1970s and 1980s now in the 1990s
more or less at the same time of the
Gulf War these people start running into
serious roadblocks economic roadblocks
to their continuous expansion these
roadblocks are linked to the existing
oligarchy regimes which are not running
these countries as according to the
principle of economic democracy or even
the principal capitalism I'll give you
an example in Saudi Arabia the Saudi
royal family which is 6,000 people own
some day land ND people of Saudi Arabia
so this is a true story of a property
development in Saudi Arabia and actually
purchase a really nice piece of land
that what he wanted to build a shopping
mall this is very popular in Saudi
Arabia now the shopping malls when the
property market is particularly buoyant
in the commercial sector for a shopping
mall so he he started he got the
approval to build a shopping mall the
design and everything so it was about to
start it and one of the lower princess
now 6,000 members
of the royal family that means that
there are people they are at the bottom
of the royal family these are people
they are constantly on the lookout for
money because they don't get a lot of
money and of course they want to run a
very expensive lifestyle so one of the
princes of the lower level heard about
it inspect the property and decided that
you could make it a good money so it
expropriated on the spot the property
developer now this can be done in Saudi
Arabia because the royal family owns the
land and the people that's just one
example so imagine what this emerging
bourgeoisie is running against on a
daily basis 'um that's why they're
putting pressure for a regime change and
the truth is that the real target of
Islamic terror is not the population of
the United States of America is not the
destruction of the US or Europe but it
is the regime change inside their own
countries they want to get rid of the
existing corrupted oligarchy regimes in
order to have a possibility to continue
to expand the reason why they're coming
after us is because we have been backing
these regimes for a long time so we're
perceiver as the power which keeping
them going and the reason why we have
have been doing that it's also for our
own interest for Western interest but
the truth is that whoever will take over
Saudi Arabia will have only one resource
to sell which is oil and you will have
only one buyer to buy which is us so
whatever happens they will have to sell
oil to us ipad i personally think that
instead of going to war we should try to
establish link may be unofficial
diplomatic links that with this
bourgeoisie with these
economic forces talk to them try to
understand what they want and work our
way through diplomacy to bring those
regime changes and make sure that the
next one that comes sooner will still
sell the oil to us and we'll still you
know give us what we need maybe a higher
price but
with Urso video
used to beat you what what is your
critical what are your critical thoughts
about our attacking Iraq this year I was
very much against attacking Iraq because
I according to my research I didn't come
across any link between al-qaeda and
Saddam Hussein on the contrary actually
came across some 1998 al-qaeda tried to
approach Saddam Hussein using his son
who died they wanted to get into the
business of all smug lehenga there was a
lot of oil which would smuggle out of
iraq during the ten years of the
sanctions saddam hussein flatly refused
any communication with al-qaeda the
reason why it did that is because saddam
hussein was actually afraid of okay Adam
it was the most serious threat to his
regime now he was a dictator but it was
a secular dictator it run the country
based upon Western principles that right
from the beginning and the only
opposition that was inside Iraq was
coming from the Islamics most of them of
course we're Shia not know soon it like
al-qaeda but the religious opposition
was the only one serious opposition so
this is why I believe that reporter I
also told that going to rock would
distract the attention and divert
resources from the real fight which is
against terror or not against one single
state but the the reason why was
particularly against and unfortunately
things now are proving that was right is
that by destabilizing Iraq we actually
gave the opportunity to Islamic armed
groups to move into the country and
establish strong goals now I describe
this in my book as the information of a
state shell
this is this is when the economy of a
country is completely destroyed by the
taking over this country by armed
organization in this case they didn't
even need to do that because it was the
war who made the economy will collapse
and that at that point they move in they
substitute their own economy which is
based on war they finance the people who
join in the war they and then there is
the birth of a sort of ancillary kind of
industry all around supporting this war
economy we see we've seen this happening
in Chechnya within this opening Bosnia
and this is exactly the same thing that
is happening in Iraq they're very
dangerous because potentially the entire
Iraq can be destabilized and can be
broken into this little shell state run
by various armed group and then I don't
know what are we going to get out of
that
Loretta napoleoni is an economist and
reporter her book is called modern jihad
tracing the dollars behind the terror
networks it's published by Pluto books
online at Pluto books calm